elon musk jeff bezos warren buffett bill
gates jack ma oprah winfrey what were
they saying before they became famous
let's find out
it's seven o'clock in the morning and
elon musk anxiously waits for his golden
payoff his prize for paying his dues in
the valley i expect to receive
a car that i've just bought which is
called mclaren airport it's a million
dollars for a car
it's
it's a it's decadent there are 62
mclarens in the world and i will own one
of them back in 95
there weren't very many people on the
internet and certainly nobody was making
any money at all
most people thought the internet was
going to be a fad
not this south african entrepreneur musk
sold his first computer program at the
age of 12 and he hasn't stopped selling
since
wow i can't believe it's actually here
it's pretty wild man just three years
ago i was showering in the at the y and
sleeping on the office floor and
now obviously i've got a million dollar
car and quite a few creature comforts
it's just a moment in my life
all clear
my values may have changed
but i'm not consciously aware of my
values having changed my fear is that we
become spoiled brats that we lose a
sense of appreciation and
perspective
a year ago musk sold his software
company zip2 which enabled newspapers to
publish online for 400 million dollars
cash receiving cash is cash i mean those
are
just a large number of ben franklin's
it's the perfect car for silicon valley
it really is
there is jonathan the fastest car in the
world i could go and buy one of the
islands in the bahamas
and turn it into my you know personal
fiefdom well i'm much more interested in
trying to
build and create a new company so this
is an atm and what we're going to do is
transform the traditional banking
industry
i do not fit the picture of a banker
thanks.com this is julie raising 50
million dollars is a matter of making a
series of phone calls
and the money is there
i've sunk the great majority of my net
worth into x.com which is the new
banking and mutual funds company on the
internet that i've started
exactly x.com i think x.com could
absolutely be a multi-billion dollar
bonanza because if you look at the
industry that x is pursuing it's the
biggest
sector of the world economy is that a
mclaren f1 yes oh my god
that's unbelievable
it's sort of like a series of poker
games and now i've gone on to a more
high-stakes broke game and just carry
those chips with me
and i haven't gone and taken my winnings
and span a big chunk but i've just
really put almost all of it back into
the new game no i'd say the real payoff
is the sense of satisfaction having
created the company that i sold yes yes
yes
but the car sure is the cars
let's be honest
it sure is you'll take the car
you talk to any of these people who have
hit the jackpot early they don't even
have a conceptualization of the amount
of money that they have it's funny money
it's something you don't need to think
about
the amazing thing is that almost none of
them quit even when they could it's not
a vesting thing it's not that there's
some secret clause in there that keeps
them from doing it they
want to do what they're doing they think
that to stop doing that is death
i'd like to be on the cover of rolling
stone that'd be cool
what you've got going on with the
internet is it's basically like an
earthquake where the epicenter is
silicon valley and it's it's shaking up
the whole world hi there who are you i'm
jeff bezos and what is your claim to
fame
i'm the founder of amazon.com
where did you get an idea for amazon.com
well three years ago i was in new york
city working for a quantitative hedge
fund when it came across the startling
statistic that web usage was growing at
2300 a year so i decided i would try and
find a business plan that made sense in
the context of that growth and i picked
books as the first best product to sell
online if you're making a list of like
20 different products that you might be
able to sell and books were great as the
first best because books are incredibly
unusual in one respect and that is that
there are more items in the book
category and there are items in any
other category by far music is number
two they're about 200 000 active music
cds at any given time but in the book
space they're more than three million
different books worldwide active and
imprint at any given time across all
languages
more than one and a half million in
english alone
so when you have that many items you can
literally build a store online that
couldn't exist any other way and that's
important right now because the web is
still an infant technology basically
right now if you can do things using a
more traditional method you probably
should do them using the more
traditional method
what kind of inventory do you keep
we inventory the best-selling books at
any given time we're inventorying in our
own warehouse only a couple of thousand
titles and then we have we do almost in
time inventory for another 400 000
titles or so we get those from a network
of electronic we
order electronically from a network of
wholesalers and distributors we order
those today they're on our loading dock
the next morning
then for another
1.1 million titles we get those directly
from 20 000 different publishers and
those can take a couple of weeks to get
and then
the uh there are a million out of print
books in our catalog we have a calendar
two and a half million books all
together those million out of print
books some of them we can get and some
of them we can't
but we find them
if we can and then we ship them to our
customers we do kind of a search on
those
what's almost in time inventory almost
in time inventory is the phrase we use
to describe a whole selection of books
that we offer it's basically the things
that are you know below the 2000th
best-selling book up to the 400 000th
bestselling book those are titles that
we can get from a network of more than a
dozen different wholesalers so if a
customer orders a book from us today we
order that book from our wholesalers
today and that book shows up on our
loading dock the next morning
and then we can ship it to the customer
they say one of the toughest things to
do on the internet is to capture mind
share what was your secret how did you
do that yeah
even more generally i agree with you
that you know capturing mind share on
the internet is extremely difficult even
more generally it's the late 20th
century not just the internet you know
capturing attention attention is the
scarce commodity of the late 20th
century and
one of the ways that you can do that and
it's the way that we did it was by doing
something new and innovative for the
first time that actually has
real value for the customer that's a
hard thing to do but if you do do that
then newspapers will write about you
what you're doing customers will tell
other customers and you'll get a huge
word of mouth fan out and and that can
really drive and accelerate businesses
and that's what happened with us in the
first year of opening amazon.com to the
public we didn't do any paid advertising
and all of our growth was fueled by word
of mouth and media exposure
i saw little ants at the bottom of the
column of the new york times that was
our very first advertising
we don't do that anymore but at the very
very beginning we did little tiny ads at
the bottom of the front page of the new
york times
i thought that was very clever it's sort
of using a url as a macro because i read
it expands we're a bookstore click here
right that's a great way to think of it
and it worked very well apparently i
don't know you know the problem with
that kind of advertising is it's
extremely difficult to track
um
put a different url for every uh
that's the problem is you want people to
start to learn your urls you don't want
to actually use a different one and
it's very
easy one of the great things about
online ads we do advertising today and
maybe 40 different
on on different websites we do banner
ads and that advertising is very easy to
track in terms of knowing how effective
it is so we know for each piece of
creative in each venue not only how many
click-throughs we get but how many
sell-throughs we get how many
dollars of revenue it generates per ad
dollar spent on that creative in that
venue and that is a sort of a marketers
uh you know nirvana in a certain sense
well it's an exciting place to be on the
web right now oh it absolutely is i mean
it's just incredible this is what's
really incredible about this is that
this is day one this is the very
beginning this is the kitty hawk stage
of electronic commerce we're moving
forward in so many different areas and
lots of different companies are as well
in the late 20th century it's just a
great time to be
alive you know we're going to find out
that
i think a millennia from now people are
going to look back and say wow the late
20th century was really a great time to
be alive on this planet i think the
president's action on steel uh probably
had something to do with the timing of
the decline but i don't think it was the
uh the the uh the factor which uh
determined the uh the amount of the
decline
for some time stocks have been rising at
uh
rather rapid rates corporate earnings
have not been rising uh dividends have
not been increasing and
uh it's not to be unexpected that
perhaps a correction of some of those
unusual factors on the upside might
occur on the downside
some observers from time to time say
that the stock market is a forecaster of
events to come can you predict would you
care to take a look at what you think
this might be forecasting the decline
the stock market has been a good
forecaster uh from time to time in the
past it also has been a rather poor
forecaster occasionally for example the
last four or five years the stock market
has been booming along and
presumably forecasting better business
which is really not materialized
corporate profits are
are not any better than they were five
years ago but stock prices are fifty
percent higher thereabouts
uh so maybe the stock market is really
uh correcting a previous incorrect
forecast this time rather than making a
new correct one well in a nutshell mr
buffett can you give us uh your opinion
of just exactly what happened what
caused it
well there was uh undoubtedly some force
selling the uh the week when the stock
market hit the news the previous week uh
prices have declined about six percent
for the week on average
and there was some stock that uh
was forced upon the market both by
margin calls from brokers and uh
some that was forced out by in
improperly secured bank loans and this
in turn set up a self-generating
mechanism on the downside for a while uh
which we may have seen the last of them
which we may not have seen the last of
the first role in investment is don't
lose
and the second rule of investment is
don't forget the first rule and that's
all the rules there are i mean that if
you buy things for far below what
they're worth and you buy a group of
them you basically don't lose money
lauren what do you consider the most
important quality for an investment
manager
it's a temperamental quality not an
intellectual quality you don't need tons
of iq in this business i mean you have
to have enough iq to get from here to
downtown omaha but uh but uh you do not
have to be able to play
three-dimensional chess or be in the top
leagues in terms of bridge playing or
something of sort you need
a stable
personality you need a temperament
that neither derives great pleasure from
being with the crowd or against the
crowd
because this is not a business where you
take polls it's a business where you
think and ben graham would say that
you're not right or wrong because a
thousand people agree with you
and you're not right or wrong because a
thousand people disagree with you you're
right because your facts and your
reasoning are right warren what do you
do that's different than 90 percent of
the money managers who are in the market
certainly most of the professional
investors focus on what the stock is
likely to do in the next year too and
there are all kinds of
all kinds of uh
arcane uh
uh methods of of of approaching that but
uh
they do not really think of themselves
as owning a piece of a business but the
real test of whether you're investing
from a value standpoint or not is
whether uh you care whether the stock
market is open tomorrow if you're making
a good investment
in a security it shouldn't bother if
they close down the stock market for
five years all the ticker tells me is
the price
and i can look at the price occasionally
to see whether the price is
outlandishly cheap or outlandishly high
but
but
prices don't tell me anything about a
business business
[Music]
business figures themselves tell me
something about a business but the price
of a stock doesn't tell me anything
about a business i would rather
value
a stock or a business first and not even
know the price so that i'm not
influenced by the price in establishing
my valuation and then look at the price
later to see whether it's way out of
line with what my value is
so buffett chose to stay in this world
omaha nebraska where corn grows just
minutes from downtown now omaha is a
nice town but nobody claims it's a world
financial center here the only
thundering herd is actually on four feet
don't you find omaha
a little bit off the beaten track for
the investment world well believe it or
not uh we get mail here and uh we get
periodicals and we get all the facts
needed to make decisions and
unlike wall street you'll notice we
don't have 50 people coming up and
whispering in our ear that we should be
doing this or that this afternoon you
appreciate the lack of stimulation here
i like the lack of stimulation we get
facts not stimulation here
how can you stay away from wall street
well if i were on wall street i'd
probably be a a lot poorer at uh
you get overstimulated in wall street
and
you hear lots of things and
and
you may you may shorten your focus and a
short focus is not conducive to
long profits and
here i can just focus on what businesses
are worth
and i don't need to be
uh in washington to figure out what the
washington post
uh newspaper is worth and i don't need
to be in new york to figure out what
some other company has worked that's
it's it's simply it's an intellectual
process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are what is the
intellectual process intellectual
processes
is
defining your level defining your area
of competence and valuing businesses
and then
within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things i'm not
competent to value but there are a few
that i am confident
have you ever bought a technology
company no i really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example ibm never
owned ibm
company i'm a sensational company but i
haven't owned ibm
and so here is this technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about
and that may be too bad but uh you know
why should i know all about them i
haven't worked that hard on them in
securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major american corporations
offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you've got
a strike call on you if you get too many
calls i know you're out in the
securities business
you sit there and they throw
us steel at 25 and they throw general
motors at 68 and you don't have to swing
at any of them they may be wonderful
pitches to swing at but if you don't
know enough you don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally get one
right there where you want it something
that you understand and then you swing
and so you might not swing for six
months you might not swing for two years
isn't that boring it would it would bore
most people and and certainly
boredom is a is a
is a problem with most professional
money managers if they if they if they
try to sit out an inning or two
not only do they get somewhat antsy but
their clients are start yelling they
start yelling swing you bum you know
from the from the stands and that's very
tough for people to do lauren your your
approach seems so simple
why doesn't everybody do it well i think
partly because it is so simple that
the academics for example focus on on
all kinds of variables partly because
academics you mean professors right yeah
the data is in business school sure and
the data is there so they focus on
whether if you buy stocks on tuesday and
sell them on friday you're better off or
if you buy them in election years
and sell them in other years you're
better off if you buy small companies
there are all these variables because
the data are there and and they learn
how to manipulate data
and as a friend of mine says to a man
with a hammer everything looks like a
nail and once you have these skills you
just
are dying to uh
to utilize them in some way but they
aren't important
uh if i were being asked to participate
in a business opportunity would it make
any difference to me whether i brought
it on a tuesday or saturday or an
election year or something it's not what
a businessman thinks about in buying
businesses so why think about it when
buying stocks because stocks are just
pieces of businesses will microsoft be
able to run without you i mean if you
fell under the proverbial bus would it
still go on without you oh absolutely
microsoft is a company with so many
great people and
uh
so much strength and
although i'm you know the most visible
part of it uh what goes on there every
day is i'm a small part of it i get to
coordinate things some of my ideas i
think are pretty good and i i'd hope you
know that the company might be worth a
little bit less if i i wasn't there to
uh get everybody pulling together and
contribute some of my
my vision but uh now we
microsoft would uh
still be the leader and continue to push
on without me i mean is there nothing
else or something else that might not
turn to you overall we had another
software billionaire who was tempted to
become president of the united states
earlier this year
might you not share that same temptation
no i i really don't see that
the
it's not a
not attractive
to me i i really like uh
what my vision of what computers can be
and some kind of involvement that is is
uh what i see for my future it's still
that same vision of the boys are in the
room next door to the massage parlor
with the long hair and the coke and the
pizza isn't it
yeah it's the same vision i mean it's
it's good to
uh become an expert in a field and you
know drive it forward and stick with it
and
it's really that rather than uh
the size of the opportunity that's
that's always made it so much fun for me
and it still is fun absolutely
foreign
i only came to co-host a talk show
because i had failed at news
and i was going to be fired
and the news director was paying me 22
000 a year
god only knows what my co-anchor was
making uh but was paying me 22 000 and
they thought they were paying me too
much money
to um
to only just do news stories
and so
i'd been taken off the six o'clock news
and was was put on the early morning
like 5 30 cut-ins and they tried to
convince me at the time they said you
know you are you're so good that you
need your own time period so we're going
to give you five minutes at 5 30
in the morning and i was devastated
because up until that point i had i'd
sort of cruised i really hadn't thought
a lot about my life or the direction it
was taking i just because i'd happened
into television happened into radio sort
of
um
i don't believe in luck i think luck is
preparation meeting opportunity but i i
felt like i had somewhat prepared myself
but that i had happenstance into it so i
thought okay i was working in nashville
and so i moved to baltimore and now then
i'll do this for a while and then i
don't know what i'll do
and so when i was called in and put on
the edge of being fired and certainly
demoted and knew that firing was only a
couple weeks away i was like devastated
i was 22 and i mean
embarrassed by the whole thing
because i'd never failed before
and
it was that failure that led to the talk
show because i had no place else to put
me they put me on a talk show one
morning
and i'm telling you the hour i
interviewed my very first interview was
the carvel ice cream man
and um
benny from all my children never forget
it and i came off the air thinking this
is what i should have been doing because
it was it was like breathing to me like
breathing you just talk
be yourself is really what i've learned
to do
and so um
from the very first day i i did my very
first talk show i felt i knew it i knew
it was the right thing to do
i felt the same thing about acting too
only i was so terrified
that um
it was a little more difficult for me
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that that's not good enough
no not for you believe nation we got to
do something but when you write it down
and you create a specific plan of action
for the next week that number jumps to
91 chance of you following through and
when you commit to somebody else like
leaving a comment on this video it jumps
to 95 you need to follow through on your
goals so what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your
specific plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you evan carmichael
is driven by success he is the president
and ceo of max the intern a successful
software development company in downtown
toronto for evan and his band of smartly
dressed merry men driving higher revenue
growth is key but not the only reason
why he's in business how much does money
drive me it's uh
it's there of course
the bigger
vision behind maxi intern is to be able
to a build an organization
where everybody involved can feel proud
of where
we come to work and we can earn money
but also have fun
be able to learn something and reach our
potential and be able to give back to
the community around us if you want to
see more successful entrepreneurs before
they were famous i have an entire
channel just dedicated to it the link to
go check it out is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there
worked on the design for about six
months and decided that we would build
our own computer
so we built them and uh